take a moment to decide any reasons you
can think of that would be compelling
for doing such a thing let me show you
one example of why it might be a good
reason to do this basically it's rarely
the case
that any piece of logic is so simple as
what we see here and you probably don't
want to retype it over and over so what
if our code instead said this obviously
I would not want to type all of this
code every time I intended to move a car
around and by abstracting it out into a
function it makes it much simpler for me
to just issue the intent that I have and
have that result in all of the changes
that are appropriate but an even more
important reason is to improve your
experience of refactoring your code down
the line if you decide you want to
change how cars in the program are
supposed to move then there's only one
part of this code that you will need to
edit it allows happen correctly in both
of the places where you called that
function imagine you wanted to alter the
way in which your cars move around the
program and you added an equation like
this which happens to be nonsense but
let's say you had something meaningful
you wanted to put in there if all the
movement logic was in one place like
this you could be confident after you've
edited this function that you've made
all the changes you need in order for
your program to start working correctly